Це неймовірно, але чиста енергія сонця - сонячна енергія - стала найдешевшим способом отримання електрики.
Навіть дешевшим за вугілля.
Але лише ТРИ ВІДСОТКИ усієї електроенергії у світі отримано за допомогою енергії сонця.
Чому ж ми так мало її використовуємо? І як вона стала такою дешевою?
А також до чого тут... качки?
Давайте розбиратися!
Спочатку подивимося, наскільки впала ціна на сонячну енергію.
Я почала працювати аналітиком у галузі сонячної енергетики в 2005-му. Тоді я думала, що це жахливо дорогий спосіб.
Дженні Чейз - очільниця відділу компанії Bloomberg NEF.
Тоді ціна сонячної батареї була 4 долари за ват. А нині ціна - 20 центів за той самий ват.
І це лише за останні 15 років. Якщо подивитися, що було раніше, падіння цін вразить ще більше.
Як же так сталося?
Це довга історія - але це неймовірно!
Грегорі Немет написав про це книгу.
Це не заслуга якоїсь однієї країни. У цьому взяли участь одразу кілька країн.
По-перше, у США з'явилася технологія…
Сучасну сонячну батарею з кремнію винайшли у США в 1954 році.
Тоді їх використовували переважно в космічній промисловості, і вони були супердорогими.
Але з розвитком технології ціни почали падати.
По-друге, в Німеччині з'явився ринок.
У 2000 році Німеччина ухвалила закон про розвиток і підтримку відновлюваних джерел енергії.
Це стало великим кроком: закон встановив фіксовану ціну на енергію, вироблену за допомогою вітру й сонця.
Це підштовхнуло громадян і компанії встановлювати сонячні панелі.
По-третє, Китай зробив їх дешевими.
Щойно німецький закон набув чинності, Китай почав виготовляти сонячні панелі з неймовірною швидкістю.
По суті, вони створили для цього цілу індустрію такого масштабу, що Захід просто не міг за ними встигати.
20 років тому про Китай у цій сфері ніхто і не чув.
А зараз це найбільший виробник сонячних панелей - до 70 відсотків світового виробництва.
Як наслідок  зараз у нас є чиста сонячна енергія, яка до того ж і економічно вигідна.
Але якщо енергія сонця така добра, чому б нам не використовувати її ще більше і просто відключити всі "брудні" електростанції?
У такої енергії є одна велика проблема.
Потрібно, аби світило сонце.
За хмарної погоди або - ще гірше - у ТЕМРЯВІ навіть від найкращих сонячних панелей - жодного зиску.
І дуже шкода, тому що саме тоді нам більш за все потрібна енергія.
Давайте поглянемо на те, як ми використовуємо енергію.
Вранці, коли більшість прокидається і збирається, нам потрібна енергія.
Так звана качина крива показує наш попит на енергію з невідновлюваних джерел, таких як вугілля і газ, протягом дня.
Спочатку там, де майже не використовують сонячну енергію. Після ранкового піку попит залишається досить високим.
Увечері, коли ми повертаємося додому, попит знову зростає. А вночі він падає.
Можна здогадатися, чому це назвали "качина крива" - схоже на качку, чи не так?
А тепер давайте подивимося, як ця крива змінюється в місцях, де багато сонячної енергії, наприклад, у Каліфорнії.
Вранці все так само. Потім сходить сонце, і починається виробництво сонячної енергії.
Це викликає падіння попиту на невідновлювану енергію.
Але лише до тих пір, поки не зайде сонце. Тоді попит злітає.
І набагато крутіше, ніж на першій кривій.
Тут є дві проблеми.
Перша: традиційні електростанції не можуть так стрімко наростити виробництво.
А це означає, що вони повинні працювати на певній потужності весь день...
...Може вийти, що посеред дня ви виробляєте більше енергії, ніж використовуєте.
Звідси друга проблема: в мережу можна пустити обмежену кількість енергії.
Занадто багато сонячної енергії може перевантажити її. Тому її потрібно позбутися.
Це завжди було перешкодою на шляху до використання ще більших обсягів сонячної енергії.
Але зараз у цієї проблеми з'явилося рішення.
Можливо, частина цього рішення зараз у ваших руках. Це літій-іонна батарея.
Ми просто беремо таку конструкцію, з'єднуємо разом дуже багато таких елементів і робимо акумуляторні батареї для машин.
А потім ми можемо їх збільшити і використовувати в стаціонарній електроенергетиці
поруч з вітряними парками або сонячними електростанціями.
За останні кілька років батареї стали набагато дешевшими. Зараз є проєкти в області сонячної енергетики,
які дозволяють зберігати сонячну енергію протягом декількох годин і тим самим
змістити генерацію із середини дня на вечір, коли попит на енергію вищий.
У штаті Нью-Мексико в США, наприклад, нещодавно вирішили закрити вугільну електростанцію і побудувати нові сонячні ферми.
Енергія, яку вони вироблять, буде зберігатися в акумуляторах.
Літій-іонні батареї стали за останні роки набагато кращими й дешевшими, ніж прогнозували.
Тепер вони стали реальною можливістю для зберігання великих обсягів сонячної енергії, бодай на кілька годин.
Тож проблема зберігання сонячної енергії відходить у минуле.
Іноді, щоправда, може знадобитися більш довгострокове зберігання. Наприклад, у менш сонячних місцях.
Тому компанії з цілого світу вже працюють над іншими рішеннями. Ось кілька з них.
Інший тип акумулятора - проточний акумулятор, де зберігання енергії відокремлене від її вироблення.
У них є дві переваги: вони можуть зберігати БІЛЬШЕ енергії.
І можуть зберігати її ДОВШЕ. Проблема: вони все ще досить дорогі.
Також існують гідросховища з насосами, які вже використовують.
Для цього потрібно два резервуари, один - вищий за інший.
Протягом дня за допомогою сонячної енергії вода з нижнього перекачується у верхній.
А вночі перетікає назад через турбіну. Але для цього потрібна горбиста місцевість і два таких резервуари.
Інше рішення, з використанням сили тяжіння, пропонує швейцарська компанія.
Вона проєктує вежу, яка за допомогою сонячної енергії піднімає будівельні блоки, а потім вивільняє енергію, опускаючи їх.
Також із сонячної енергії можна виробляти "зелений" водень.
А з воднем можна робити що завгодно: заправляти ним автомобілі або навіть виробляти сталь.
Я гадаю, що зберігати сонячну енергію будуть переважно в літій-іонних батареях, у водні, може, ще кілька варіантів…
Я вважаю, що диверсифікація підходів - це добре.
Але літій-іонні батареї стають настільки доступними, що іншим буде складно з ними конкурувати.
Але у них є й інші переваги. Наприклад, вони можуть довше зберігати заряд, що може зіграти ключову роль у деяких випадках.
Отже, сонячна енергія стала дешевою. А проблема зберігання практично вирішена. Що далі?
Станеться бум. Сонячна енергія буде всюди.
Наш прогноз: навіть без втручання політиків сонячна енергетика до 2050 року становитиме 23% від світової енергетики.
А особисто я думаю, що навіть більше.
Я не здивуюся, якщо до 2030 року значна частина світової енергетики буде залежати від сонця.
Сонячна енергетика пройшла довгий шлях.
І зараз, у світлі останніх технологічних відкриттів, настав її час засяяти.